seriously Apple stop playing games and
just give us the M3 chip already I don't
care if it's an iMac or a MacBook Air
just give me that sweet 3 NM goodness
that I've literally been waiting for the
past 2 years for we hoped it would show
up with the M2 Chip but no we even had a
bunch of leaks and rumors pointing to
the M2 Pro and Max getting 3 nmet but no
again we got 5 NM plus plus and earlier
this year we had people betting on these
3 NM Max finally coming in June but now
that we're getting into the fall we're
getting even worse leaks of news by the
day so Apple when the heck are they
coming well in this video we're going to
try and make sense of all of these
recent rumors like the weirdest one of
all that we just got from Mark German
and tried to puzzle piece the entire
lineup and when we should expect each
chip to come like the M3 the M3 Pro the
M3 Max and the ultra so let's get
started back in March of this year mark
German reported that there was evidence
Apple was readying its next range of
Maxs including a new iMac with the M3
chip then in may he found evidence of
Apple already testing a MacBook Pro with
an M3 Pro chip with clear evidence in
developer logs in July he reported that
Apple's first M3 powered Max are likely
to launch in October yes this month and
including a 13-in air a 13-in MacBook
Pro and that same iMac but just the
other day he came out with some pretty
bad news saying that each M3 Mac has
ultimately been delayed until
2024 and this actually matches what M
quo recently said with it being unlikely
to get any new Macs at all until next
year and even more specifically he said
that the 24-in iMac for sure is not
coming until 20 24 even though we
recently had leaks of an imminent M2 and
M2 pro version of the iMac coming very
soon which is apparently wrong as well
so to everyone's disappointment we might
not be getting any new Macs until next
year but honestly does this make any
sense at all and what if everybody is
wrong because if you think about it the
very first M1 Max were revealed in
November of 2020 and almost exactly one
1.5 years later we got the M2 Chip
setting us up for a 1.5 year Apple
silicon M series chip cycle compared to
the once a year cycle for the iPhone
chips and yep you guessed it 1.5 years
after the M2 would put us right in line
with November of this year being the
perfect opportunity for an M3 chip
reveal but to crush everyone's dreams M
Cho just came out with a brand new
report from his suppliers saying that
shipments of components that are planned
to be going into max this upcoming
fourth quarter of the year are down 25
to 35% compared to last year this
essentially means that Apple themselves
are expecting MacBook sales to be down
by basically that much in the fourth
quarter which also hints at no new Max
launching because if there were the
demand would definitely shoot up quo
also pointed out that MacBook sales as a
whole this year are expected to be 30%
lower compared to
2022 which is honestly really bad with
lower than expected sales for the 15-in
MacBook Air that we had last summer and
ultimately he believes that apple is
intentionally choosing to withhold the
launch of any new Mac products with the
goal of clearing existing inventories
ahead of the huge M3 chip releas
releases and why would Apple do this
well I think I know the reasons but
first I want to get into the very
specific crazy weird leak that we just
got from Mark German in his latest power
on newsletter he said that we should be
expecting four new MacBooks in
20124 but the release dates are the
exact opposite of what makes sense
apparently the 14 and 16-in high-end
MacBook Pros with the M3 Pro and M3 Max
chips are coming first between early
2024 and the spring and then on the
other hand the 13-in MacBook ear that we
were all expecting this month is
actually earlier in the production phase
in the engineering verification testing
phase which means that we might not see
them until the spring or even summer at
the earliest in my view this is
incredibly weird because Apple has been
releasing the lower-end M chips first
first and then going up the line to the
pro the Max and the ultra chips but now
they're seemingly flipped so what the
heck is going on Apple well I think I
know what's going on so let's get right
into it with reason number one being the
economy the economy is definitely not in
the same place as it was last year with
people having less disposable income to
spend leading to less demand for Tech
products in general especially
especially PCS and smartphones with
demand for each category going down
student loan repayments have just
restarted and many people in Tech have
been getting laid off over the last few
months and a good number of people are
also taking pay cuts these days with new
jobs with some companies actually asking
their employees to take pay cuts so why
would Apple release their incredible M3
Max while demand has been going lower
and lower which could ruin this launch
why not just just sit it out and wait
until we have hopes of economic recovery
next year but now getting into reason
number two I personally have been saying
for a while that it makes sense for
Apple to start Apple silicon chip
development on their higher-end chips
first with the Mac chip and then
bringing the tech down to smaller chips
like the iPhone a series chips why well
to avoid the major yield issue that
Apple just went through with the brand
new 3 NM a17 Pro chip in the new iPhone
15 Pro which is an extremely high volume
product moving millions of units in a
short period of time why not introduce
the latest chip Tech in lower volume
products like the high-end MacBooks
first giving apple and tsmc time and
experience to work through yield issues
and any flaws in the chip making process
so they can more easily prepare the
chips for the mass Market iPhones and
now for reason Reon number three because
of all of the yield issues negatively
impacting the performance and efficiency
of the a17 pro chip what if those issues
caused Apple to delay the mass Market M3
MacBook airs if there simply weren't
enough chip yields for both the new
iPhones and consumer MacBooks at the
same time what if it makes more sense to
first use the same problematic n3b chip
process for the high-end MacBook Pros
which don't sell as many unit
and then actually delay the M3 chip
until the next Generation n3e process is
ready so then n3e would debut on the M3
chip and then later in September it
would be brought to the iPhones allowing
time to work through any issues while
selling these MacBook airs that could be
a good enough reason for Apple to
weirdly delay the M3 longer than we
expected temporarily breaking the 1.5e
update cycle so they could reset with a
new cycle next year Apple unfortunately
chose to release the 15-in air this past
summer with the same 1-year-old M2 Chip
which was a bit of a disappointment to
those waiting on the M3 which created a
dilemma that caused many people who
wanted the 15in to hold off on
purchasing it because of the hype for
the M3 chip that we expected this fall
so if Apple released just the 13in M3
air this fall there would be an even
bigger dilemma for people who wanted the
bigger 15in size but would be left with
the old M2 Chip so sales would get even
worse and of course if they chose to
update the 13 and 15 at the same time
with the M3 chip this fall that would
mean the 15in M2 would have basically
the shortest lifespan ever with many
upset customers so because of that Apple
could be delaying the 13-in air alt
together until next year so they can f
finally release both the 13 and 15in
models together getting them on the same
update cycle which they naturally should
have been in the first place it's all
just a mess of a situation and
unfortunately if true people holding off
for the M3 MacBook Air are going to have
to wait longer than we thought so
hopefully you enjoyed this updated leaks
video and if you did you can subscribe
above and check out our video on iPad
leaks right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video